[Music]
hello everyone a very good morning to
you
some of the world's biggest social media
companies are joining forces with the
government
to encourage young people to get the
covid vaccine demand is already soaring
with more than
a million appointments booked in just
two days after the vaccination program
was open to all remaining adults
it's a clear sign the public is more
determined than ever to make sure the
delay to easing or restrictions
which was scheduled as you know for
today
doesn't happen again jemima walker
reports
cues like these outside vaccine centers
it's clear many young people
don't need encouragement to roll up
their sleeves
when booking open to over 18s nhs
england saw more than one million
appointments made in two days
that's six jabs booked every second
but the ons says vaccine hesitancy is
highest in the under 30s
and the virus is spreading fastest among
young people
that's why the government is teaming up
with social media giants to make sure
young people have the right information
it's really important that young people
express themselves we know that they
come to platforms like snap to do that
they talk to their best mates
they have a whole bunch of creative
expression as well and
stickers is one way to do that but i
think snap's role in this is to make
sure that we get factual credible
information
and give young people the confidence to
make that decision for themselves
social media is already helping to
spread the news about pop-up vaccination
hubs
new filters and stickers let people show
off their vaccine
status everybody's like got the stickers
and stuff that you can attach to the
polls
yeah i feel like that's kind of
influential for the people that
telling us stuff as well with hashtags
we just turned 18
and like we're definitely probably like
the biggest like
demographic that are turning up here
right now in a statement the health
secretary matt hancock says
i'm delighted that snapchat reddit
ticktock and youtube
some of the biggest social media
platforms are coming together to support
the most successful vaccine effort in
nhs history
the relationship between social media
companies and the government hasn't
always been an easy one during the
pandemic with online platforms
criticized for not doing enough to stop
the spread of disinformation and
anti-vaccine sentiments
scientists say inoculating the young
will now help protect
everyone we know that vaccinating groups
that contribute
the most transmission can actually have
a really significant impact in bringing
transmission down at population level
and even protecting people who are more
vulnerable if we want
everyone in our population to be
protected we need to have the maximal
uptake of vaccines
particularly among groups that are most
likely to mix
with the new freedom day creeping closer
the government wants to turbo charge
vaccinations
it's hope social media can play a part
in getting the over 18s to come forward
jeremiah walker sky news
business energy and industrial strategy
secretary's busy isn't it quasi quatting
is with us hello good morning thank you
for joining us
what are the social benefits of being
vaccinated twice
i think they give you huge protection
gives people confidence
and also i think it protects other
people
from from being infected so there are
huge benefits from
two uh two vaccinations absolutely yeah
but what about the social benefits i'm
thinking particularly about
looking at the figures 0.4 of travelers
that have
come back from ambalistic countries have
tested positive that's 89 people out of
more than almost 23 and a half thousand
people who've had two vaccines should
they have to uh quarantine on their
return from holiday so the
the figures that you uh quote i think
were stated in the times today
um and those figures don't tell the full
picture yes they are statistics
they're very encouraging but you can
appreciate that we want to keep people
as safe as possible
and that's why we've maintained the
amber list
but do you acknowledge that people who
are having two jobs are getting more and
more frustrated thinking
okay i'm protecting other people but
there have to be some other social
benefits for me whether that means i
don't have to quarantine
if i go on holiday or if i come into
contact with somebody who's had covered
i don't have to self-isolate which is in
fact what matt hancock is suggesting
so i i totally get the frustration i
mean
for for me uh it's been very difficult
because i want to i want to go on
holiday but i've chosen
uh not to because of the restrictions
the guidelines
i think it's a difficult one to balance
uh it's encouraging as you say the data
we've seen
uh from ambulance countries but at the
moment uh we want to take
an approach that's more uh safer rather
than sorry
and what about as i said developing from
matt hancock's uh wanting to ditch the
stay at home order
for people who have come in contact with
people who have covered if they've had
two
jabs yeah i think matt uh is clearly
very close to the information he's
worked
extremely hard over more than a year now
and what he says
there's a lot of a force to what he says
i don't know what the final decision
will be
but as we've all always done through
this process
uh we've been more cautious perhaps than
a lot of people would have liked
but of course we got a duty to keep
people safe more cautious than perhaps
you would have liked but
um i'm sure you saw the scenes in
leicester square with the football
these scotland fans at the weekend
no social distancing there at all what's
the government's view on that
i think it's really uh difficult because
we want people to act responsibly
and i saw the pictures as well i think
it's really concerning that
lots of people were congregating in this
way but it's very difficult
thing to police um i mean i saw the game
as i think
you did it was rubbish it was a rubbish
game but that's
not if you're a scotland fan obviously
good morning everyone in scotland if
you're an england fan maybe not so much
putting the quality of the football
to one side i think yeah it is it is a
problem but again we've got to do to
strike that balance between essentially
compelling people how to behave
and then giving guidelines so that
people can accessibly in this instance
it was very concerning the behavior but
you can appreciate the frustration then
of the nighttime industry and nightclub
owners people who we've got someone on
later on who has six theaters in the
west end and they're not allowed
to play at full capacity i i get their
frustrations i mean as you said
well what we're going to do is we set
out a roadmap and hopefully on the 19th
of july
uh everything can revert back to some
type of normality
could it be before the 19th of july i
think between you and me i would always
uh er on the side of caution and i would
look to the 19th of july it could be
before but i think that's unlikely
do you well i don't know i mean that's
just my guess uh generally we've stuck
to the dates that we've set
um i remember in the previous dates
there was a lot of push to try and get
the dates the 12th of april earlier the
17th of may earlier
that didn't happen and i think now i'm
very focused on the 19th of july
the reason i'm slightly pressing you on
that is because there has been criticism
of the prime minister this morning
that he doesn't throw his net wide
enough to ask his ministers and cabinet
minister's permission he just relies
on a core group of ministers and and
from what you're saying it does sound as
though he doesn't
he doesn't reach out to people like you
and say he doesn't so what's he saying
about the 19. so
so you'll appreciate that uh today's the
21st so the 19th is four weeks time
and all through this process we've said
that we would take the decision a week
before
uh the actual date because the data's
moving around all the time but you
appreciate how frustrating that is for
the
night time industry that we've just
talked about trying to organize
reopening
i i fully appreciate that but kay you'll
know that
the coronavirus is quite unpredictable
we don't know where it'll be
even in two weeks time let alone four
weeks time and what the prime minister's
always said is that we've got to look at
the data in real time we've got to look
at the data
as it comes and then make a judgment uh
soon
in between the the dates that means that
we've got to
look at the data and we can't make a
decision
a month or five weeks before the actual
date um
it's what we do know is it's costing us
a fortune and this pandemic how are we
gonna pay for it
i think it's a very difficult uh
question to answer i'm hopeful
as business sector as you can imagine
that we can grow the economy
and that's in the past has always been
the best way
to raise tax revenue to grow an economy
have a prosperous economy
and then the tax revenue from a thriving
economy can pay down
some of the debt that's what's happened
in the past happened after the second
year this is a massive jet isn't it
the second one was a huge sure the
suggestion is that it's going to be a
pension rate
um that's flying a kite in the papers
this morning the telegraph particularly
i i don't think i mean obviously we're
discussing uh lots of things are being
discussed in government i don't think
that that's
uh necessarily the way so you think a
triple lot will stay in place as far as
i'm pretty sure
the triple obviously the decision for
the chancellor but i'm pretty sure the
triple log will stay
talk to me about by-elections uh you got
an absolute kicking
last week um we for all sorts of reasons
sure
um battling spen is looming on the
horizon we heard the former speaker
speaking yesterday john berkow here on
sky actually
suggesting that the prime minister only
has a nodding acquaintance with the
truth
um labour are pressing hard for a
planning debate planning was a big issue
as far as badly
as far as amisham was concerned how
anxious are you about the first of july
because if you lose another one
it's a it's a lot of trouble look by
election is always difficult i mean you
and i remember uh by-elections were
always challenging have always been
challenging for governments
in fact it's very unusual uh for a
sitting government to win
a seat off the opposition has happened
in hartlepool uh six weeks ago
so by-elections are difficult i think it
was a very disappointing result
last week in cheshire and amisham and
we're looking to learn lessons from that
anyone would
try and learn lessons from what was a
very difficult uh
set of results but you're not a
government that's used to losing
you seem to have been doing very well of
late in previous uh elections
is it down to uh planning and and the
issues that we saw there in amisham or
is it a bigger problem for you are you
concentrating
too much on the red wall and ignoring
the blue wall i don't think that's true
i mean i think
as you know by-elections are always a
mixture of national issues
and local issues i think last week in
cheshire and amisham the local issues
played quite strongly uh there was a lot
of talk about hs2 there was a lot of
talk about the government people said
people saying the government wasn't
listening on planning
we are listening we want to engage with
our mps i have a southern seat as well
where this is a big
a big issue and we want to engage now
about winning elections yes it's nice to
win elections but generally
as you remember uh governments tend to
lose by elections in in midterm i mean
that's what
has happened historically i think we've
had a good run but
uh we're not taking anything for granted
i think the the election
next week will be very difficult for us
uh it's a historic labor seat
um but we will try our best to win it so
from what you're saying it sounds as
though you're setting yourself up for
failure
no not at all i mean i'm very realistic
and i look back at
lots of mid-term results which have been
very disappointing in government for for
years
um and i think it would be foolish for
us to expect
a miraculous a really a really good win
i think we've got to just try and
work hard for every vote be humble in
the face of
the voters and and see if we can get a
result
i'm not underestimating how difficult uh
batley and spun will be
where are we on the prime minister's
credibility though we talked about uh
the former speaker there
saying that you know he he he sees the
truth
uh maybe once every leap year and then
we've seen dominic cummings absolutely
ripping him to bits he's going to do it
again later on today he's going to have
a live q and a session
how much damage are noises off during
the prime minister i think the prime
minister
and what is his great strength is that
he's very very focused on the job at
hand he's very very focused
on providing leadership and as you say a
lot of people
recognize that that's why we've had
successful results in
places like hartlepool which was
historically unprecedented
and he's very focused people say all
sorts of things about prime ministers
um from time to time sometimes they say
bad things but that won't detract from
the prime minister's focus
on what is a very difficult situation
but when they impact on his credibility
that's when it starts to damage the
party that's when it starts to damage
the government
well i don't think they have necessarily
impacted on his credibility i mean i've
been reading about boris johnson for 30
years people have said all sorts of
things about him
uh in the past and nothing prime
minister nothing has
really detracted from uh his focus on
the job you'll remember he's i mean he's
done the job for nearly two years now
and that whole period before the general
election in december 2019
there are all sorts of things being
written about the prime minister being
written about the party
being written about the fact that you
know we took the whip off of people and
all that sort of thing
but we were very focused the prime
minister was extremely focused
uh on getting a mandate on the election
uh and he remains very focused on
leveling up and and driving his agenda
so people like dominic cummings and
people like
uh uh the uh what's that what's
backhoe's first name i've controlled
john burke are to be ignored well i
think
uh they can say what they say in the
media but our job as ministers
and the prime minister's job is to focus
on getting us out of a very difficult
situation with covid that's
100 of our our focus at the moment and
we cannot jot what people like that
thing well i read in the papers and and
i might make for my own judgments but
i'm 100 focused on the job
okay we also read in the papers about a
royal yacht
really um he wants to spend 200 million
pounds on it
um the prime minister apparently the
royal family don't want it
and the treasury the mod and the cabinet
office are all refusing
to pay for everybody's falling out
nobody wants this royal yacht why does
he want one
i think there's a discussion in
government about uh the yacht
i'm not sure any conclusions have been
reached and there's a degree of
agreement i mean i'm speaking to
colleagues and we're we're trying to
mull over the
those issues but i think it's a good
idea actually why do you think it's a
good idea because actually what it does
is that it
it represents uh britain it's a symbol
of britain
and if we're going on trade missions
that's exactly the way that we would uh
we would drive uh trade and it's a
symbol of
britain i'm sure it'll get much more
bang we'll get much more bang
for our buck from something like that uh
than than
the opposite but if the royals don't
want to say who's going to get it it's
just going to be you and boris
it's not going to be just so i'm just
going to him i'm not that big i can't
[ __ ] off seriously but at the moment
you know we do have trade delegations we
have people representing
the country to try and get really good
deals liz trust my colleague is doing a
fabulous job in that regard
and that sort of thing is something that
can drive
trade as a symbol but you can see how it
might be ridiculed by
voters in battley and spain uh when
they're they're struggling to feed their
kids at the moment and we're talking
about spending 200 million quid on our
yacht that the royals don't want
it's a huge amount of money but then it
would only be
the decision to to spend that money
would only be made if we felt that we
could get a return
from something as symbolic as that and
and it would be something which would
really enhance what we call our soft
power you know in terms of doing deals
it's not a decision that's going to be
made anytime soon
well it's it's something that's being
discussed i can't tell you when exactly
the decision was made okay it's good to
talk to you thank you
so much for taking the time to join us
thank you really appreciate it
still to come on the program for you
this morning 7 30 joined by the shadow
secretary for international trade
emily thornbury can
the show go on i speak to the boss of
six theatres who's hoping the delay to
eating
all coveted restrictions today is the
last they have to cope with
and as young people flock to get their
coveted jabs could the robot be extended
to 16 and 17 year olds gonna be speaking
to the government's scientific advisor
professor callum semple that's at five
past
eight and just a reminder if you want to
catch up on any of that interview or
watch the program when you're out and
about this morning you can of course
with the sky news mobile app go to our
website
go into our live blog to watch the
program live and you can catch up on the
interviews on my twitter feed
as well that's at k burley
new flexible rail tickets go on sale
from today catering for commuters who
are only going into work two or three
days
a week so how is it going to work let's
speak to shaman freeman powell who's in
the newsroom for us this morning looking
fabulous as always shiman good morning
to you tell us more
good morning yes so these plans will
offer discounts for
passengers traveling two or three days a
week
now they've been dubbed as the biggest
reform to railway
travel in a generation and it comes
after
figures released earlier this month
showed that travel numbers on
on trains had reached its lowest level
since 1870
now this is because more and more people
have been working from home during the
pandemic
but now businesses are being encouraged
to offer hybrid working
but the problem is trains are very
expensive and many people
can't actually afford to commute part
times
so to commute part-time so these plans
are hope to to address this
and will offer these discounts they can
be used from the 28th of june
and the department for transport have
done some analysis on these
and say that some big savings can be
made on certain routes
for example people traveling for only
two days a week can save more than 230
pounds if they're traveling between
liverpool and manchester if their
communitates in between welcome
at woking and london twice a week that
they can save
260 pounds and if commuters are
traveling for three days
rather than the full week from
chelmsford to stratford
in east london they can save 350 pounds
now anthony smith from the transport
watchdog has welcomed
this announcement he said that it will
be useful for some passengers
and is described as a positive step
towards much needed
long-term reform on how rail tickets are
sold
okay for now thank you thanks a lot some
of the other headlines for you this
monday morning's the longest day today
it's emerged that eight
vulnerable children i'm afraid were
among 10 people killed in a
multi-vehicle crash in alabama over the
weekend
the incident happened on a road that had
been soaked with rain because of a
tropical depression
those killed were traveling to a home
for abused
and neglected young people
mayor of greater manchester andy burnham
has accused the scottish government of
hypocrisy after it announced a travel
ban to parts of north west england
nicola sturgeon pinpointed manchester
and salford as
cohen hot spots and announced that all
non-essential travel to the areas would
be banned from today
despite case rates in the cities
matching those in parts of scotland
italy has introduced a mandatory
five-day quarantine for visitors
arriving from britain because of
concerns over the increasing number of
covet cases
in the uk travelers from the united
states canada japan and some other
european countries
will be allowed into italy as long as
they have a coveted 19 green
pass looking at the latest coveted
figures in the uk then
there have been 9284 new coronavirus
cases
six more deaths have been reported that
means the total number of people who
have died within 28 days
of a positive test now stands at 127
976.
another 280 241 people have received
their
first vaccination and 236
363 people have received their second
in total 31.3 million people have now
received both doses
of a covid vaccine and we were hearing
from the minister within the last few
moments that that could potentially mean
more social freedom for people who've
had both vaccines whether that means
you've come into contact with somebody
who is positive of covert 19 and you may
not have to quarantine in future
he said quite a lot about that and also
if you've got
two jabs does that mean that when you
come back from an anabalistic country
you don't need to quarantine find out
what he said in just a few moments
meantime all spectators
at the 2022 world cup in qatar will have
to be fully vaccinated against the
coronavirus to get into the games
the organizers are also hoping to obtain
a million vaccines
in order to immunise fans from countries
who have not been able to vaccinate
all citizens and in japan olympic
organizers are expected to decide on
whether to allow domestic spectators
into venues during the games
japan is moving ahead with staging the
multi-million multi-billion dollar games
which were delayed by a year due to the
pandemic despite
worrying and worries about a resurgence
in covid 19
infections and public opposition the
opening ceremony is now just over a
month
away well
it might be coming home but not
necessarily to england wales
have booked their place in the knockout
stages of the euro 2020s despite losing
their final group
b game against italy harriet hatfield
joined welch fans at a bar in cardiff
busy celebrating their narrow defeat
this was the moment wales went through
to the knockout stages of euro 2020
losing one nil in their final group
match against italy
with the landlord more than a thousand
miles away captaining the national side
welsh fans superstar player gareth
bale's cardiff bar
were proud of the team's performance
[Music]
a few hours earlier welsh fans had
streamed into the stadio olimpico
in rome a win for wales would have been
an upset
but just in case some fans had made a
complicated journey
it's been a bit problematic a lot of
covered tests
you know a lot of buses a lot of trains
but food from manchester in the end we
got here it's fine
the first half was lively but italy
dominated
wales won a corner in the 26th minute
chris gunter's header was close
but not close enough then mateo posina
turned
italy's free kick into the first goal of
the game
but just five minutes before half time
italy were delighted
but a slightly subdued reaction back
home in cardiff
it was a techie second half for wales
down to 10 men
after eaton ampadu was given a red card
the youngest
ever player to be sent off during the
euros
then local hero bale missed wales's
biggest chance of a goal
wales held out with some frenetic
defending as the game drew to a close
but as the match ended it was a relieved
welsh side
this is what it's all about you know to
get into the second tournament here in
succession
and do so well we should be proud of
ourselves the country should be proud we
should be loving it
in many ways barring a disaster win or
lose it was always going to be win-win
for wales
they now go through to the final 16. the
only question now
is could it be england or maybe even
scotland
joining them in the next stages of the
tournament
whoever they meet in the next game wales
fans hope
the team can find a little bit of that
recent welsh footballing magic
harriet hadfield sky news cardiff
[Applause]
i'm going to play tomorrow i think don't
they czech republic all right and saying
that i think that's right
um let's see how they get on they
thought it was a walk in the park
against scotland that'll teach him now
it's the archbishop of canterbury like
you've never seen him
before justin welby has taken to the
streets of cambridge
to get a taste of life as a big issue
vendor the archbishop donned a baseball
cap and spent time trying to persuade
the public to purchase
a magazine from him the archbishop was
selling alongside local vendor lee
wellam
at his pitch outside the round church in
cambridge
let's find out what's happening as far
as the weather is concerned uh today for
big issue sellers and the rest of us
good morning
good morning good morning well as you
mentioned earlier it's the summer
solstice
today um it's not going to feel very
summery for some areas but a
vast majority of us will have a mostly
dry and bright day
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
good morning it's the summer solstice
today but not feeling that summery
across southern parts of the uk where
there will be spells of rain cloudy
skies as well
some heavy downpours with that rain in
fact this morning it's already a wet
start across many southern counties of
england
and there are some heavy downpours with
some of that rain elsewhere it's a
mainly dry and bright start to the day
in fact it's quite chilly in some spots
particularly across the northwest where
there's an isolated ground for us the
temperatures are only a degree or so
above freezing
there is also some patchy light rain and
drizzle across southern parts of
scotland
some areas of northern ireland tune just
pushing into northern parts of england
but otherwise mainly dry and bright
going into this afternoon we continue
with that rain along southern counties
of england
that will be still heavy at times
spreading up towards parts of east
anglia for a time as well eventually it
will ease later
at the same time that's cloud the patchy
light rain across southern scotland
clears from southern scotland and
northern ireland
down to the north of england and wales
becoming increasingly cloudy for parts
of the midlands and the south of wales
elsewhere island northern ireland
scotland
mainly dry and sunny
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
big by-election coming up uh labour
really needs to win it will they
speaking to the shadows secretary for
international trade
emily thornbury next
[Music]
so queer's a a word that has kind of
changed over the years in the 70s gay
men would use the word
to describe themselves and then when i
was a kid in the kind of 80s and 90s it
became a term of abuse
so i think it's uh it's all about
context if someone drove past in a car
and shouted the word of me that wouldn't
be great
but in this context the word queer is
great to use and it's a
positive inclusive term that refers to
members of the lgbtq plus community
the premises i ask my heroes to write a
piece about one of their lgbtq plus
heroes
so we've got people like elton john
olympian
gus kenwa the queer eyes uh tan france
we've got activist monroe bergdorf we've
got comedian may martin
it's a brilliant roster of um my heroes
who are writing about the people that
changed their lives
the essays are really moving they're
funny um they're inspiring and they're
about the moment when
these people people like elton john kind
of realized who they were
um accepted themselves and loved
themselves so yeah it's
the roster's incredible it's basically
my dream party lineup it would be the
best party ever if we all got together
elton john really why it's really
honestly um
it's a really funny brilliant essay it's
very moving as well
and it shows a different side to elton
that some people might not be
be aware of but all the essays do that
graham norton's written an incredible
essay about the writer armistead malpin
and it's the opening i don't want to
spoil it but it's one of the funniest
things i've ever read in my life
so you go from nearly wetting yourself
to two pages later nearly crying
and that sums up to me the beauty of the
lgbtq plus community you know there is
a lot of pain there is a lot of trauma
um we do go through a lot of difficult
times but at the end of it it's a
celebration and that's what i want the
queer bible book to be
and i'm really happy it's coming out in
pride because it's party time
[Music]
hello my name is nadja frantier
my name is ryan matthews i'm the marine
assistant
at rather a research station which is to
the west of the west antarctic peninsula
so far i've been here for five months
and it is an absolutely wonderful
experience
my name is fatima zazile the founder of
ikesa from kuwait where we face many
environmental
problems related to waste pollution the
frustration
and lack of information we are
collecting recyclables
from houses schools and businesses in
order to recycle them
exchange if you're recyclable to get a
tree
hello again a very warm welcome to this
monday morning as demand soars for
vaccinations with
more than a million appointments booked
in just two days
after the vaccination program was open
to all remaining adults
a little while ago spoke to the business
secretary quasiquating
i asked if there was any chance of the
government easing restrictions before
its terminus date
of the 19th of july i think
between you and me i would always uh er
on the side of caution
and i would look to the 19th of july it
could be before but i think that's
unlikely
do you well i don't know i mean that's
just my guess uh generally we've stuck
to the dates that we've said
um i remember in the previous dates
there was a lot of push to try and get
the dates the 12th of april earlier the
17th of may earlier
that didn't happen and i think now i'm
very focused on the 19th of july
this morning is as you can see uh the um
what title should we use for you today
you've got so many i never know which
one to call you
you can just call me emily if you like
talking about vaccines and double
vaccines um
should we look potentially at being
released before the 19th of july as a
result
look i have always said i continue to
say
we should be led by the science we
should be led by advice
and i think there's something in us all
moving at the same time i mean i'm lucky
to have been second vaccinated but i
know that
there's many people in their 20s who've
made huge sacrifices who haven't yet
and we we should be working as one one
community honestly so being double
vaccinated shouldn't afford people any
extra privileges i don't think so not at
the moment i think we have to stick
together we've expected everybody to
stick together
we've expected these youngsters to make
all these sacrifices i don't see why
we should uh we should now have a
divided society we need to work together
because the health secretary is
suggesting that if we've been double
vaccinated
we don't need to quarantine if we come
in or isolate if we come into contact
with somebody
who is suffering from covert yeah well i
understand that i understand that all
i'm saying
is that i think it's pretty cool galling
the point i'm trying to make kay is it's
pretty galling for a 25 year old
who's made all the sacrifices that they
have who may have lost their job
who you know all the difficulties that
we know the youngsters have had
to then see the pubs filled up with you
know with people of my age
you know enjoying themselves and them
being quite limited and what they can do
i just want us to stick together it's
only another month or so
and i think that you know we have
achieved so much as a
as a nation and i'm so proud of her so i
just don't want us to
to lose that in the last push but should
there be some exemptions
like the fact that you've been double
vaccinated you don't have to
uh isolate if you've if you come into
contact with somebody's got covered i
think
you know we have to go with the science
we have to go with the advice what's
your thought
i think we have to go with the science
and go with the advice just to clarify
what are you saying are you saying that
you should you can you
that the health secretary is correct
that if you've had two jobs you don't
need you shouldn't have to quarantine or
not
i think that if the health secretary is
acting on advice then
and is and is uh giving it giving
messages that have been decided
collectively on the basis of advice and
listening to scientists then that's fine
if he's freelancing as we have seen some
of the ministers doing then that's a
different matter
they do have to be clear about their
messages and
that's what we've always needed the
british people want to do the right
thing they just need to know what it is
they've got to do
um what do you think about the message
in this morning's paper suggesting
that potentially there could be a raid
on pensions to try to pay
for the pandemic i don't know the
details of this
and i need to we need to look quite
carefully at what the ramifications are
um i think that we will need to be
we need to make sure that we that we
invest properly in order to get out of
the pandemic
you know we need to get our economy
going and it will be to the advantage of
everybody to do that we have to get the
economy going which will mean
that we will need there will need to be
investment on it but i can't say at the
moment where that
whether we should what what the plans
are particularly in relation to pensions
i know that suggestions have been put
forward this morning
but i'd like to see the details before i
mean it's cost us
absolutely fortunate how on earth would
labour start to pay for i know
i mean it would have cost us even more
if people had all lost their jobs of
course
and if we had completely wrecked the
economy and we weren't in a position to
be able to come out of it again
i do think that as we come out we will
grow our economy will grow
and people will be how do we cook those
hundreds of bills well i think that what
happens is that the economy grows as we
come out of this pandemic and then you
know through taxation where if
if the economy booms then you can get
more you can get more funding from that
can't you because you can get more
more money from taxation an increase in
taxation
well we'll have to see what happens
we'll have to see i mean i think you
need to have an open mind at this stage
we can say that but labour presumably in
the background
is looking at um if they were in power
how they would be
trying to start to rebuild our economy
and thus putting the government on the
back foot
i think the the trouble is when you're
such a long way out from a general
election and things are as unstable as
they are it's very difficult for us to
start putting forward
tax and spend plans at this stage it's
frustrating but that's the truth
and i don't see why we should be
untruthful with the nation
you know that's yeah i understand that
but i think i'm probably pressing you on
because you have got another by-election
that's coming up in just
a very short period you were absolutely
tranced weren't you in in cheshire
you've not won a by-election since
2012. so people will want to know not
won an election release since 2012.
so people will want to know what
labour's policies are on things like
getting us out of this pandemic and how
we're going to pay for it
but i think that a by-election has a
particular nature and that is
who do you want to have to represent you
unfortunately it's not a general
election if it was a general election
then listen you know if i wasn't if i
wasn't giving you full answers you'd be
absolutely in a position to complain
but a by-election is about do you want
to have an absolutely extraordinary
labor candidate or the dory and that's
the choice that the people
of that constituency have at the moment
and i would just ask them to look very
carefully at
you who would stand up for them best
only 1.6 of those that voted in cheshire
wanted labour
that's the bloody nose isn't it i didn't
end up campaigning in cheshire but i did
speak to a lot of people who went
and they said that there was there was
no doubt that
people were completely fed up with the
conservatives and were looking for an
alternative and looking for a way of
defeating them
and it was decided that the lib demons
were the way to go
and so we got a lot of people who will
give labor a second chance
but at the moment in that by-election
they wanted to send the message to the
tories and i'll tell you
the message was don't take us for
granted i get the same message actually
when it comes to the the um deal
the trade deal with with australia i
mean lots of people getting
conservatives getting in touch with me
saying why is it that you are talking
about farming
and about protecting farming in a way
that the conservatives aren't these days
i mean they do
seem to be taking people for granted and
taking areas for granted
and people are fed up with it they're
not going to have it and they will have
their own way of expressing things
we had it today with the with the
opposition day motion that we have in
parliament today which is about planning
people feel the same
way they feel like you know local
democracies being trounced
that big developers are just having
their way with the conservative party
the conservative party is just going to
let them develop as and where they want
to willy-nilly
and it's not right what does it say
about kyocera's leadership if you lose
batley in spain
i don't think it says i think it says no
more than
by-elections are odd things and there
can be a whole range of different
factors in a by-election
particularly in a pandemic which is also
a peculiar time
and i don't think you can have a read
across from that to
making any great pronouncements about
about leadership about where the labour
party is at this precise
it's a snapshot but i don't think it
says anything more generally
i think a general election is different
to a by-election you know you and i have
seen enough
violations to know that we can't make
great pronouncements
what about the latest opinion poll that
says 20 only 24 percent of people think
that sakir has what it takes to be a
good prime minister
i think they haven't seen him yet i
think
they're never going to well i know but
there's a pandemic and it's quite
different i mean
has he actually made a speech in front
of an audience yeah doesn't need to
that's what social media is for
and we're not in front of an audience
that said we are ah
yeah but it's it's quite difficult
actually for him to be able to lay out a
store for people to know who he is
in the middle of a pandemic i mean this
is not easy and i think so half an hour
at prime minister's questions more or
less
every wednesday to make his points and
how much of that is covered
do you know what i mean it's live on sky
and that's good live on other
broadcasters as well how many people
have
this opportunity to showcase his
policies yes but what proportion the
population even see that
well it's then picked up in the
newspapers he sends pics if he makes a
point it's then picked up on other
broadcasters as well he has a platform
all i'm saying
is just not using it according to 76
percent of the population that was
well 76 the people that 76 percent of
people that took part in the latest poll
give him a chance let's see the end of
the palace we need to get out of the
pandemic and then he needs to have his
chance right he needs to have his chance
to show who he is and to show his medal
and what have you got
in the by-election it's a it's a
by-election we will move on we will we
will move on from that you know he needs
to be able
to be given his chance and people need
to hear him and meet him and know who he
is
and know that he is so much a better
potential prime minister than the one
that we have at the moment
we'll leave it there it's good to talk
to you thank you for joining us on the
programme this morning
thank you still to come on the program
uh if you are heading out
of the door and you want to watch the
interview again with
um the stormbury or indeed with any of
the other
guests this morning all you need to do
is have a look at the sky news app you
need to go
online and then you click on the sky
news app or you can watch the key points
at moment by moment
uh on our website
tamara's here 20k thoughts
well i think we're getting same message
from
all parties in terms of caution about
when those who are double jabs can enjoy
more freedoms
than those who aren't of course there's
this question of whether it
discriminates against younger people
we've had
as tougher time as anyone else but
labour not
directly calling uh for the government
to give freedoms to the double jabs
although we understand it's being
intensely uh discussed in government and
of course i think we see the set
stage set for the coming months debates
about we've spent a huge amount of money
doing covered hundreds i couldn't
believe it was it like 300 billion i
couldn't believe
the institute for government put it at
340 billion more than was forecast
i mean they have to try and recoup some
of this money
somewhere rishi sunak was a chancellor
who enjoyed doling out the money
on the furlough scheme and saving other
bits of the economy now he's going to
have to be the chancellor who reigns
that spending in
we're already hearing that he's looking
at pension contributions as a potential
place to to raid that money from the
triple lock on pensions quasi-cuatang
told you
he didn't think that would be scrapped
but we know that it's going to cost
a lot of money this year because it's
linked to average earnings and they are
actually up because it's lower paid
people who've tended to lose their jobs
so where are they going to be looking
and and emily thornberry didn't want to
lay out where
uh she thought label would be looking
she didn't but neither
i thought it was fascinating what she
was saying about kia stammer
yes there are jitters in labour about
kierstama and she just said wait
give him a bit of a chance we need to
get to know him better
and it's already uh well over a year
into his leadership
but he doesn't have a platform but what
sort of platform does he need i wonder
well i think he's been saying
that during the pandemic he's been
unable to go out and make speeches
he doesn't have the crowds behind him at
prime minister's question time he had to
give his
leadership speech when he won the
leadership in his living room it's been
a bit of an odd period
but we are where we are the prime
minister has some of the same
constraints
and um i think if labour are going to
lose this by-election in battle and
spend next
thursday that's a seat they've held
since 1997 that would probably
prompt some jitters about where sakir
stami's leadership's going well let's
see for now tomorrow thank you
expert analysis as always from tomorrow
um coming up in just a few moments uh
can the show go on i
speak to the boss of six theatres who's
hoping the delay to eating all covered
restrictions today
is the last they have to cope with
[Music]
our house was severely damaged by the
blast in beirut
i was concerned we were unable to locate
ralmo
the chilean mine rescue was the most
amazing story i've ever covered
kipchogen had always been this rock star
of running
pushing through the city all of a sudden
we were there looking at the tower of
saddam
21 personal stories from some of the
biggest news events of the last 21 years
storycast 21 available now wherever you
get your podcasts
[Music]
[Applause]
oh we should protect our heritage
unfortunately it will become part of
azerbaijan
this monastery is under the protection
for now the next five years at least of
russian peacekeepers
i'm diana magni and i'm sky's russia
correspondent based here in moscow
[Music]
i witnessed the despair of the armenians
in nagorno-karabakh who were digging up
the soil of their dead relatives
it's armenians who've abandoned these
villages now
despite what their strategy is i'm not
sure but they have made
some arrests already today
they can't kill everyone they can't
shoot everyone they they can't arrest
everybody
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
[Music]
i mean this clearly says i love hitler
are you saying that
doesn't say hitler
[Music]
russia insists that its military buildup
in the arctic is purely defensive
[Music]
i'm stuart ramsey and i'm sky's chief
correspondent
[Music]
done
did you know symptoms of hay fever can
develop at any stage of life
not just in childhood the pollen reports
sponsored by philips connected air
purifiers
rain with heavy downpours will affect
many southern counties of
england today as well as parts of east
anglia elsewhere will be mainly dry with
bright or sunny spells except across
parts of northern england and later the
north of wales
where it will be largely cloudy with
showery rain clearing from southern
scotland
and northern ireland pollen levels will
be high for most of northern england the
midlands and wales today
elsewhere will experience moderate
levels but the far northeast of scotland
will be low
currently grass pollen is in peak season
and fungal spores are at
medium risk there's also lots of weed
pollen mainly
nettle the pollen reports
sponsored by philips connected air
purifiers
uk theaters were first forced to close
their doors back in march 2020 and while
today was supposed to be freedom day yep
21st of june
the sector faces yet another anxious
wait for the government's so-called new
terminus day which is the
19th of july joined now by the uh chief
executive of
nymax theatres that's nica burns hello
to you
good morning talk to me about the how
you felt when you heard that the 21st of
june was being pushed back to the 19th
of july
well it was a huge blow uh because
we've been gearing up and uh it's about
really reigniting reigniting the shows
you know these big shows take a lot of
planning
and it involves giving jobs to many many
people so
there are all these people anxiously
waiting the moment when the producers
would turn around and say
we're on and of course there's there's a
lot of good messages
before we got the bad news and it was a
blow
and we're just going to have to look
forward and hope
that when we get july the 19th it really
happens
um you are what capacity are you running
at at the moment
and what do you need to run at in order
for some of those box office shows to
actually make any money for you
well we're running at a maximum of 50
but actually with all the seats you have
to take out for social distancing
it's not as much as that so probably
across my six theaters we're running at
40
box office now that is not enough if you
have a big show so
a show like uh harry potter and the
cursed child at the palace theatre which
is a theatre i own
we can't bring that back because it's
300 000
plus a week just to run let alone all
the set
up cost the production and for some of
the shows even bigger than that is
it's much more than 300 000 pounds so
for those shows
really you need to be 100 potential but
if you could do 75 or 80 percent
that would at least mean that we could
open what did you think of lord lloyd
webber saying he was going to
open and be damned come and arrest me
i thought that was incredibly brave of
him and
great leadership his show
is a premiere and it's been in
rehearsals already for some time
on the basis that we were expected to be
able to open from what the governor told
us
so he was just trying to keep his show
together all his actors and
150 plus people involved in it
in work and also audiences have been
flocking to go
so this big box office but at the end of
the day
he knows that he can't put everybody
else into
a legal position so which is why he's
withdrawn it
but it was an act of great showmanship
and it just
wasn't possible and what measures do you
imagine will still be
left in place uh even after the 19th of
july what impact will that have on you
well i we don't know yet um getting
feedback from the audiences we've had
over a hundred thousand people through
our doors
um since we reopened at 50 capacity the
smaller shows
and the message we're getting is that
they
there's still an interim time when
people feel that they need to be
safe next the person sitting next to
them a stranger the moment with the
social distancing
they're not in contact with anyone so i
think that they will still be mask
wearing
um i think there will be there may well
be a system of code certification which
means you have to show you've either
been vaccinated
you've got antigens or you've got a
current negative test which just back
covers everybody
and as far as looking at football fans
gathering in leicester square at the
weekend just up the road from where some
of your theaters are
how do you feel about that well
that's been our point all the way
through kay i mean theater is a very
organized
environment people come in they appear
to see a show they might have a drink
but they're not gonna have ten drinks
and they it's a very they look forward
they don't
really interact with each other they're
here to do something with their mates
so we go well why are we being treated
so much more harshly
when actually going to say the theater
is very safe
nico it's good to talk to you thanks for
joining us this morning thanks a lot
quickly
look at the weather for you now
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning it's the summer solstice
today but it's not really going to be
feeling all that summery across
southern parts of the uk in fact this
morning it's a wet start to the day
across many southern counties of england
with spells of rain that are rather
heavy and quite cloudy
just to the north of that around some
central areas the rest of england wales
starting off mainly dry and bright but
across the far north it's quite cloudy
into southern parts of scotland
areas of northern ireland down towards
uh central northern parts of ireland
there are some cloudy skies and
patchy-like rain and drizzle whereas
further north and west it's a
bright but chilly start to the day in
fact an isolated ground frost in some
spots across the far north
now going into this afternoon we
continue with the spells of rain across
southern counties of england still some
heavy downpours spreading up towards
parts of east anglia as well but
eventually that rain
should tend to ease but ahead of it
parts of central england the midlands
the south the world's becoming cloudier
and across southern parts of scotland
becoming dry and bright as that cloud
and patchy rain
sinks its way further southwards down
towards northern parts of both england
and wales so england well's generally
cloudy by the end of today with patchy
rain to the north
heavier rain down towards the southeast
whereas across ireland northern ireland
scotland
far north of england later as well it
will be mainly dry and bright and
feeling fine in any sunshine
tonight that rain eventually clears from
the southeast dry clear and chilly
elsewhere tomorrow
a much drier day
the weather sponsored by qatar airways